folks in Los Angeles are losing their
collective noggins over the Dodger blue
and the manager of the National League
champion Los Angeles Dodgers on the day
before Game one of the World Series Dave
Roberts kind enough to call into the
show how are you skipper rich I'm doing
well man thanks for having me on you got
it what emotions are coursing through
your veins right now Dave I think you
know what I'm trying to temper them
there's a ton to be quite honest
obviously and a lot of excitement and
just trying to tell myself take it one
game at a time but obviously that's hard
to to do when you when you walk around
Los Angeles and you hear and see all the
energy and all the text messages that
you get and so are you thinking about
the journey of your career your life I
mean are you are you thinking big
picture like that Dave you know what I
think that there's moments like that
rich yeah there's moments like that and
you kind of look back and wonder how you
got here to this moment and but a lot of
it is just focusing you know on this
world series and trying to finish what
we started in you know focus on on the
Astros and then there's always a journey
for the actual season that you'd love to
finish with one last champagne shower
what moment this season can you recall
where you thought okay this team special
we got thought we got ourselves a chance
to win a championship this year I think
it was you know I mean I to be quite
honest I knew from the beginning that
the talent was in the room I knew that
it was a special special group and when
we talked about this day one of spring
training but rich all all season long
our guys were so pious but I think the
second after that seat of the season
where we were behind and yoshio hit a
homer we played well up going into the
break and and we were down late to the
Marlins in that first game of the second
half and you know you never want that
little hangover after the break in
he had a big walk-off home or a home or
late and we ended up winning that game
off their closer Ramos and I just
thought at that point in time this is
our seat okay Dave Roberts Dodger
manager joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about right now
right here right now is Clayton Kershaw
100% healthy day
he's 100% rich he's 100% you know you
look at all the the posters that he's
been through this is a the lightest
workflow that he's had and obviously
never been in the World Series so he's
mentally physically raring to go okay so
is if necessary load him up game one see
Sally yeah I mean he feels good he's so
strong through a great game in Chicago
so obviously we're gonna load them up
but it is nice we have a pen that's
really arrested and again there's a
seven or eight guys that get in the
truck okay and then in terms of your
lineup do you know right here right now
is we're chatting right now what your
lineups gonna be do you think for game I
do I do I think that it's we have a
pretty set left-handed lineup and so I
think that we're gonna run those same
guys out there against Keiko on Game one
and why would you make a decision like
that walk me through that if you don't
mind well I think that our guys you know
the season that they really had success
against left-handed pitching obviously
the only question being is corey seager
where i expect him to be in the lineup
we'll see he's tracking the right way
feeling good but austin bar going to
play Cody Bellinger Justin Turner
obviously and Kiki Hernandez that we
platoon in left field and he's I had a
tremendous postseason three homers so
he'll play against the lefty but a lot
of it is what with my eyes tell me and
also just kind of what the numbers say
too
so would you say Seager is a game-time
decision I guess to use a football
phrase I think I'm certain he'll be
active and we just want to make sure
that you know that he's healthy enough
and if we have to buy him an extra day
we'll do that but I would say sort of
rich a game time decision but I expect
to be on the rock okay and in terms of
keeping your players healthy I imagine
just keeping them away from key case
high fives would be something that's
very important for you right now right
he was fired up you know three homers in
the postseason so yeah he came into that
tiny little dug in and Wrigley Field he
came in hot and just a couple of players
I want to hit with you right here Dave
Roberts Dodger manager day before World
Series Game one calling in here to the
Rich Eisen show we discussed when we
wait
chatted about a couple months ago about
yasiel puig and how when you guys made a
decision to send him down to Oklahoma
City last year a lot of folks thought
that it was he was not redeemable as a
talent let alone the guy that we're
seeing right now did you have a
conversation with him at any point in
September about the the big October
that's to come and have a sit-down with
him about keeping his emotions in check
and then channeling it in the positive
ways that we're seeing mostly you know
III did I I did wish and and with yasiel
like many of our players out a lot of
conversations but I think with him
especially I want to make sure that you
know we were on the same page and I
think that he appreciates the the the
candidness of a conversation and holding
him accountable and myself accountable
but yeah going into this up going into
October we had a conversation in
September and just kind of really trying
to challenge him to focus on every pitch
and understanding that the most
important thing as we approach October
there is no switch to kind of like flip
it on when the post season comes and the
focus for three and a half hours has to
be there and the goal is to help the
Dodgers win baseball games so we're I
was very clear he was very in tune with
that and he was completely on board so I
mean did you don't you run the risk of
maybe Haley naming where where he feels
you don't trust him because you're
having this conversation I think the
thing rich was with the Osceola's he
appreciates like most people is just
directness and I think that you know
when you can be honest and forthright I
think that he appreciates that and for
us for two years we have that
relationship where I'm honest with him
and challenge him and have certain
expectations and if they're not met then
there's a consequences and I follow
doing that with that as well so I know
it's him and I there's a mutual respect
and love so yeah I've got no problem
having that difficult conversation did
you have a conversation with him after
he kind of bat slipped on a double Dave
no I I didn't that's kind of you know
the thing is Richard there's a
you know playing the game the right way
but also taking a person's kind of
natural kind of enthusiasm away and as
long as he's playing the game the right
way I've got no problem yeah I mean I'd
be honest with you just seeing him just
the way he's gone about his business and
then having fun while owning it and then
licking his bat and all of this stuff
it's it's great it's just you know a fun
atmosphere you're supposed to have fun
have fun and is it the days when so when
Ted Williams played and Maury wills or
Don Newcombe or Jackie whoever no it's
not Bob Gibson would have his neck if he
saw someone lick his bat when he was in
the batter's box but you know what the
games change which we know that the fans
love it and this guy still is an asset
he's helping the dogs from Facebook and
then I want to talk about Justin Turner
what he has become how do you as a is a
skipper just continue to harness a magic
carpet ride and ascension into
superstardom for this guy who years ago
didn't even possibly for many observers
have such a path for his career how do
you maintain this you know what rich you
said it right it's a magical ascension
and and I think that but he's a magical
person and he's a heck of a baseball
player and all the things that have come
his way he's earned and no one works
harder he's as blue-collar as they get
he loves being a Dodger he's a winner
and you know in big spots man this guy
didn't shy away for the big moment and
so I've said it many times rich he's the
glue to our ballclub and we wouldn't be
here without him all right so then let's
just in a couple minutes we have left
turn our attention to the other
clubhouse and dugout Dave Roberts Dodger
manager here Jose Altuve is a revelation
just and somebody like yourself in the
positions that you played and I guess
the if you don't mind physical stature
you know just seeing what this guy does
and how the team and the fan base plugs
into what he's doing what do you think
you need to do to try and bottle up Jose
Altuve for this series David yeah I mean
this guy this guy's an MVP
you see the statues you mentioned but
this guy there's nothing on that
baseball field he can't do and it's just
remarkable to see and and it's hard as a
fan not to root for a guy like goes out
to the but now when you're in the
opposite Doug yet obviously you know
it's a tall task to try to figure out a
way to contain this guy I think just
mixing locations changing speeds because
if you walk over he can still a base and
if you uh you know leave it in the zone
he can slug you so you just gotta kind
of keep him guessing but yeah the guy
can run so he gets on base a lot of
different ways and he they go as he does
so he's that one guy thing rich every
team you sort of identify what guy you
don't want to beat you and he's that guy
you know and then the ALCS MVP and
Justin Verlander he appears to be is
locked in as possible was there any
point where there was a conversations
about you guys we were absolutely were
on him you know there were conversations
and he's a heck of a heck of a pitcher
he's a number one obviously and yeah I
mean we were really looking into it but
I but I think the contract and all that
stuff kind of what you inherit and I
don't know all that stuff rich but I
know that he was definitely in
conversations but obviously a huge coup
for the Astros but we're gonna have our
hands full game two it's Earl Andrew no
doubt and two more for you look I know
you you take whoever you want to get
whoever you know the baseball gods
placed in front of you and the Astros
are a top-notch team and potentially
world championship caliber but didn't
the 2004 version of Dave Roberts one
thing Yankees in that building you know
what rich I'll tell you what I was torn
in the sense of for baseball the purity
the history Dodgers Giants it would have
been iconic I mean I Dodgers Yankees
would have been iconic but one of my
good friends is in the other dugout over
there AJ Hinch so I was good for him too
so you know what for me honestly the
Indians and the Astros are the best team
all year in American League so it's
something where the Astros started off
really well made the deadline trade with
Verlander and I think the two best teams
are playing silver World Series and I
know Curt
and I know Kirk Gibson's out of the
country who's throwing out the
ceremonial first pitch do you know
tomorrow I don't know I don't know
they're keeping it under wraps man I
don't got to do so I'm not in the know
maybe it's banned could it be van or
Tommy could be Tommy out there I mean
I'm sure it's gonna be someone special
and I'm pretty I'm excited with
anticipation colfax maybe and Wow cursor
on the mat will look a good luck I know
it's gonna be red hot to be about a
hundred degrees for first pitch for a
Fall Classic coming up on Tuesday so
have a great series and i truly
appreciate you calling in once again to
the show you bet that's Dave Roberts
Dodgers manager for more Rich Eisen show
tuned - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Rich Eisen show app